what's up guys recently AMD has just
been absolutely killing it with the
risin and thread ripper here they are
coming out with risin - very soon so
should you wait for Raisa - well this is
very simple if you don't need an upgrade
then just wait but it is going to be
revealed very soon and it is definitely
worth seeing what they have in store
it's not that long void if you need a PC
immediately then just get the best you
can afford right now because risin -
well most likely just be an incremental
upgrade the 2800 X is not going to have
poor cores and 24 threads at five point
one gigahertz like a the rumors suggest
that rumor is really fake if you are a
professional then a few hundred dollars
won't matter for you and you might as
well just go with Intel skylake X trees
biggest most productivity soft first
like Premiere Pro are more suited and
optimized for Intel CPUs right now if
you are a gamer and want the best gaming
CPL out there then you might as well
just get the 8700 k because whatever AMD
comes out with simply won't match the
performance of the 8700 k because of the
lack of optimization and core clock in
my opinion Rison - won't be that much
better maybe a 10% upgrade if we are
lucky but even then the current rise in
processors will drop in price and so
will their corresponding other worse so
it is better to just wait it is very
straightforward just wait if you can and
you can't then get the best you can
afford right now it's as simple as that
if you guys are wondering if you should
wait for intel's canada lake then make
sure to check out my video about that by
clicking a link right here that video is
way more in detail and lengthy because
that subject it's way more subjective
but that's all i have for you guys this
time if you like this straightforward
answer then make sure to drop a like on
this video i would like to see what you
guys think he said make sure to comment
them down below if you guys would like
to see more videos just like this and
extra then make sure subscribe and hit
that Bell notification to be notified
whenever I post a video but definitely
hard for you guys this time until next
video bye